Come to the end of the year,
so I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about
the whole course today,
I guess,
and trying to sum up what
might be most useful to remember about
it
and when we started at the beginning I
made the case to you that people have
been studying personality and its
transformations for a very long period
of time and that the earliest
forms of knowledge that we have about
what people are liking,
how they change
come to us from stories and from very,
very old stories
and
it was stories represent how people act
in the world fundamentally rather than
what the world is made of
and the fact that people are confused
about that is part of the reason that
there's still tremendous confusion about
the proper relationship between science
and religion or science and ethics.
Almost all of the
forms of information transfer that we
regard as engaging our narrative in
their format.
We love stories and the reason for that
is that stories tell us how,
what people are like and how they behave
and they present the world as a place in
which people behave.
And so the stories help us understand
how people behave,
but they also help us understand how
people must and should behave given that
they have a certain nature and that they
have to organize their behavior with
other people,
and so that puts a set of very serious
constraints on how it is that people
can exist in the world.
The story's basically take two forms.
One form is the description of people
acting in motivated states of one form
or another,
and those are usually motivated states
that everyone is familiar with.
Most stories,
whether they're archaic or modern,
have to do with exploration and
adventure or romance,
and the reason for that is that
we're.
We're biologically constructed so that
were adventuresome,
exploratory and interested in intimate
relationships and so the stories reflect
that and they help us understand
how
those fundamental motivations could be
manifested in behavior in a manner
that's productive,
partly for each individual and then
partly for the individuals in
relationship to other individuals and to
families and to broader communities.
The other form of story that seems to be
of critical importance from a historical
perspective is stories that describe
transformation and transformation tends
to be represented as I'm
using symbolism that's associated with
death and rebirth and the reason for
that seems to be that
almost inevitably when you learn
something new,
you learn it because something that
you're doing or something that you're
using to structure your perceptions no
longer works,
so pursuit produces a result that you
don't intend.
And because of that,
before you can learn to restructure your
behavior,
you have to allow yourself to let go of
the things that you're doing that are in
error.
And those can be small things in
situations where only a small correction
is required.
But sometimes they can be very large
space and if they're very large things,
then it's as if there's a large element
of your personality or yourself that has
to degenerate and transform itself into
chaos and then reemerge.
Hopefully restructured
and
the archaic stories about death and
rebirth and the transfiguration of the
soul are stories about the necessity of
disillusion and disintegration preceding
asset.
And it's a very useful thing to know
because it means,
first of all,
that you're going to be resistant to
learning things as you progress through
life because every time you learn
something,
you have to let go of something that you
hold dear before you can reconstruct
yourself.
And so that accounts for people's
unwillingness to learn things and
unwillingness to face facts that don't,
that aren't in accordance with their
current view of the world.
Um,
but it also helps you understand that it
might be worth letting go of the things
that you're doing that aren't productive
because even if it's painful in the
short term,
the consequence might be the kind of
personality transfer information that
stops you from having to suffer stupidly
as you move through life.
In.
One of the reasons that I
titled This Course Personality and its
transformations is because the
transformation part of the study of
personality is probably more important
than the study of personality traits
themselves.
This is part of the reason why,
for example,
Piaget thought it was much more
important to learn how it was that
people learn things,
that it was to learn what they were
learning.
So he was more concerned about the
process by which people generate
information and transform their
personalities.
Then he was in determining the nature of
whatever theory it was that people
happen to be using to interact with the
world at a particular historical stage
or at a particular developmental stage.
And I think one of the things that's
most important to learn from our CAC
stories,
which is where we started this,
is that,
um,
it's much more,
it's much more useful to envision
yourself as something that can
continually transform in response to
challenge than it is to view yourself as
the static embodiment of any particular
strategy of knowledge or perception.
And you know,
one of the things that you'll see quite
frequently,
and you certainly see this in
universities now,
I think perhaps you see that the
university is more than you see it
anywhere else,
is that people adopt astatic ideological
stance on the world and they try to
interpret everything that happens in the
world through the lens of that static
ideology.
They try to compress the entire world
into that particular theoretical
framework and become extraordinarily
upset when the phenomena that confront
them don't fit in accordance with the
ideology and the reason that people do
that is because they identify themselves
with their ideological beliefs and
they're static ideological beliefs.
Instead of identifying themselves with
the part of their personality that's
capable of continually assimilating new
information and accommodating to it or
transforming and you're much more
powerful person.
If you can.
If you can understand that what's most
essential to you as your capacity to
transmute and transform as challenges
come towards you rather than your
ability to to develop a coherent and all
encompassing totalitarian theory and
attempt to impose it on the world.
I think one of the most tragic
mistakes that modern universities make,
especially on the humanities ends of the
distribution,
is that people come to university
looking for orientation in the world,
looking for ways of understanding it,
and essentially they're taught two
things and one is that there is no
fundamental meaning to things and so
that if your rationalist,
if you're rational and intelligent,
being that you're only reasonable
outlook is nihilistic,
and then what seems to go along with
that is some insistence that you adopt a
particular ideological stance as some
sort of counter position to that.
And to me that has nothing to do with
education at all.
That's just.
That's a.
that's.
That's corruption from both directions
because there was no real utility and
nihilism and there's no reason to assume
that it's the appropriate stance on
life.
And everything we've learned from the
20th century indicates that there's
virtually nothing that you can do that's
more dangerous personally and socially
than to grasp an ideology and to attempt
to apply it to everything that comes
your way.
And so the fact that universities teach
people how to do that in some
reasonable.
Rick reasonably rigorous way is I think,
nothing short of appalling and I think
the only way that you can,
that you can transcend that is to
understand that what you know is not as
important as what you yet,
what you have yet to learn,
and what that means is that you can.
People often find strength in regarding
themselves as the sort of being that can
comprehend everything and that's that
sort of being that's competent.
And and,
and what would you say,
sufficiently well developed at the
current point so that they have the
appropriate answers to the appropriate
questions.
But the thing about that that's wrong is
that you don't have the answers and
often you don't even have the questions.
And so if you can identify it with your
capacity to learn,
that means that you don't have to be
afraid of the things that you don't
know.
And that means that you can listen to
people and you can discover new things
and that you can continually make your
personality expand and transform.
And we have no idea what the limits are
to the human capacity to transfer,
to expand and transform.
And you're,
you're much more powerful from an
existential perspective if you regard
yourself as the sort of person who can
surf on change rather than someone who
has to make everything static and
unchangeable just so that they can adapt
to it.
So I learned a lot of that from reading
archaic stories and trying to understand
exactly what it was that they were
trying to,
to communicate to people and the
fundamental communication is that it's
reasonable to conceptualize the world as
a place of action rather than a place of
objects.
And then to regard the central problem
of human life,
the existential problem as how is it
that you should look in the world and
look at the world and act on it,
you know,
and,
and from a,
from a scientific perspective,
that's generally regarded as something
that's at the phenomenal because
behavioral analysis of appropriate
behavior falls into the domain of ethics
and philosophy.
But that's foolish for people because
everything we do revolves around how we
have to look at the world and how we
have to act.
This is part of the reason that I talked
to you about piaget because I think
piaget had had had cottoned onto
something that was unbelievably profound
and it's an element of getting and
thinking that generally you don't hear
much about.
If you take courses on piaget,
especially in relationship to
developmental psychology,
especially North Americans like to
reduce piaget to a list of developmental
stages and that is something that piaget
really wasn't all that concerned about.
He was interested in how the processes
that people use or how the structures
that people use to interpret the world
transform across time,
but he wasn't particularly interested in
exactly what those stages were and how
they see actually followed.
One another and piaget is a fundamental
idea was that
there were ways of organizing complex
systems that could sustain themselves
with very little input of energy and
effort and resources
and the fact that those forms of
organization exists meant that some
forms of organization were better than
others.
And the reason that that's so important
is because piaget,
for example,
is one of the only thing that I've ever
come across that managed to transform
what you might think about as a
qualitative evaluation,
so an evaluation,
say of the appropriateness of a solution
to a problem,
like a moral problem.
He managed to transform the discussion
of that into something that was
virtually quantitative and so piaget's
idea of the equivalent rated state was
the notion that you could set up a
complicated system so that all the parts
of the system,
we're operating in some kind of
harmonious balance.
So the system wasn't continually
fighting itself either at any given
moment in time or in multiple situations
across time.
And so for Piaget and celebrated state
was the state was a state that was
relatively free of conflict and so it's,
it's.
I started with piaget instead of Freud
because because people often start
personality courses with Freud.
Piaget actually had the model for how
people organize themselves.
I think he had a more accurate
representation of the model of how
people organize themselves than Freud
did.
Now you know that Freud conceptualize
people as an ego,
right?
With tremendous id like forces
underneath pushing the ego around and we
would think about those as classical
biologically motivated or biologically
predicated motivations like aggression
and sexuality and all of the other
elements of our motivated behavior that
make us animal like Freud thought.
If the ego is trapped between those and
the demands of the social world.
And so he thought of that as an
intrinsically conflict laden process
where you know you're trying to manifest
all.
You have your animal instincts as a,
as an animalistic individual and society
is attempting to him that in and and
repress it and and inhibited.
Because as a pure manifestation of
biological and melody,
you're dangerous and not properly.
You know,
you're.
You can't fit into a social environment
without inhibiting that are sublimating
it or transforming it at some in some
manner.
Whereas the Piagetian perspective is,
is,
is more something that's predicated on
the idea of a game.
And I think it's a more sophisticated
way of looking at it because when you
look at how children organized their
personalities,
especially between the ages of two and
four,
it's certainly the case that to some
degree,
they learned to inhibit their impulses
as a consequence of social pressure.
But it's much more,
it's much more appropriate and accurate
to notice that actually what they mostly
learned to do between the ages of two
and four is get along with themselves
and get along with others.
And so what's happening is,
you know,
they,
they burst onto the world with a set of
sub personalities that are predicated in
biological reality.
So they're hungry and they're thirsty
and they have to maintain their body
temperature to a certain level.
And they have to learn how to cope with
all of the demands of being a biological
entity like,
like toilet training and,
and,
uh,
learning how to share and learning how
to play with siblings and establishing a
relationship with parents and so forth
and so on.
But the way they seem to do that is by
organizing their behavior into more and
more complicated and sophisticated games
that stack on top of one another,
you know,
so the child learns how to regulate
their biological rhythms and go to sleep
at the appropriate time and wake up at
the appropriate time and if the parents
scaffold them properly,
then they learned to eat at the proper
time so that so that the.
So the,
the,
the.
They're not dysregulated by,
by,
by starvation or hunger or thirst and
they're not dysregulated by temperature
extremes and they learned how to
incorporate their aggression into
cooperative games rather than how to
inhibit it and they make their
personalities more and more
sophisticated as they're doing that and
they learn how to play a larger and
larger number of more and more
complicated games with more and more
people.
And that's a kind of hierarchical
organization that extends inside the
person in so far as they're organizing
their fundamental biological motivations
and their emotions and then starts to
extend beyond the individual as they
start to organize their fundamental
motivations and their emotions.
Well,
other people are doing the same thing
and it's out of that continual interplay
of game,
like cooperation and competition that
it,
that society itself emerges and that's
not on an inhibitory or conflict laden
model.
The conflict between society and the
individual in the Piagetian model only
occurs when the when the game like
structure of the personality is not
sophisticated enough to interact
properly with the environment at that
point and so you can see that the,
that the idea of a pig and equilibrated
state is that you could imagine an
individual at all of the levels of
existence that the individual exists at
from,
you know,
the micro caused them the micro world
way down at the Subatomic,
in the atomic level,
stacked up on top of each other all the
way up to the societal level so that
everything in that hierarchical
organization organization is working to
make every level work properly.
And that's,
I think,
I think it's a really good model for,
for what you might conceptualize as,
as,
as mental health.
Broadly speaking.
Because your mental health is of course
dependent on the appropriate
organization of your psychophysiology.
But it's also dependent on the earth and
the integration of that organized
psychophysiology into an intimate
relationship and then into a familial
relationship and into a relationship
with the community and then into a
relationship with the structures that
are beyond the community.
And you know the fact that many of your
concern,
for example,
with environmental issues means that you
understand at some level that in order
for your being to be optimized,
you also have to exist in some
relatively harmonious manner inside
large biological ecosystems.
So economic ecosystems and political
ecosystems and social ecosystems and
biological ecosystems and all of those
levels have to be stacked on top of one
another.
So each level supports and fosters all
the other levels.
And that's a very complicated.
That's a very complicated thing to
attain.
And it's also something that has to be
continually negotiate it and transformed
because of course you're trying to stack
all these processes in a hierarchical
manner,
in a self sustaining hierarchical manner
in an environment that also continues to
shift and move.
So not only do you have to stack up this
structure to begin with and and organize
it,
but you have to transform it at whatever
level needs to be transformed as you
move throughout the dynamic environment.
That changes from day to day.
It's a very complicated process.
Now it seems to me that that one of the
things that you can come to understand,
and this is something that I took at
least in part from,
from reading you,
is that that the process that you engage
in when you're organizing your
personality in this hierarchical
structure and the process that you
engage in,
well you're updating.
It actually manifests itself as
intrinsically meaningful.
So there's.
There's,
there's an element of your off your
intrinsic being that's actually devoted
towards fostering that process and when
people talk about the idea that life
might have some meaning,
it seems to me that you can actually
experience that meeting when you're
engaged in the process of producing this
hierarchically organized structure and
balancing and maintaining it across
time.
And I think,
and this is and idea too,
I think that what you experienced that
as his engagement when you're very much
interested in something that you're
doing and you're sunk right into it so
that you're not even self conscious and
so that time itself isn't ticking away
in a painful manner,
but,
but something that you're not even
really aware of.
You're not even aware of time
progressing when you're in that sort of
state.
Then that's a signal from your,
from your.
I wouldn't say from your nervous system,
but from being itself that you're in a
position where all the levels of being
are properly organized.
And I think that people experienced that
as a deeply meaningful state of being.
And I don't think that that has anything
to do with rationality.
You know,
because you can as nature pointed out
when we talked about the
existentialists,
you know,
you can make a very strong case that
from a rational perspective that life is
devoid of meaning.
But the problem with that is that it
starts out with the presupposition that
the rational analysis of the situation
that brings that question to life is the
proper level of analysis.
And I don't think there's any evidence
for that at all.
You know,
one of the things that Carl Rogers
continually pointed out in his
phenomenological approach was that to
evaluate how you're progressing through
life,
you cannot only rely on your
rationality,
it's a mistake because you're an
embodied creature and you're constantly
being informed by all sorts of processes
that can't be reduced to straightforward
rationality.
And that it's a mistake to assume that
the rational mode of interpretation of
experience from moment to moment is the
one that should actually be super
superordinate.
And it's,
it's a mistake partly because you're
more complicated than your rationality.
And so is existence itself is being
itself,
you know?
And,
and for the existentialists and the
phenomenologists,
especially following heidegger,
the question was the nature of being.
And I think that's the proper question
to pose to yourself when you're trying
to assess exactly what constitutes the
human personality.
You know when these things to me as part
of the reason that I was so interested
in the existential approach because the
existentialist take the idea one step
further and it's in a very complicated
and sophisticated way.
Now they they make the case that you
have an ethical responsibility to being
and so that would be to your being,
but to being a general in the ethical
responsibilities that you have to
confront it straightforwardly and
honestly and the way that the 19th and
20th century existentialists came to.
That was really twofold.
It was mostly from the negative
direction,
so people like frank girl and social
units and when they were pushing the
idea that it was necessary to have a
truthful relationship with being.
The reason they came up with that
conclusion was by observing those
circumstances where people clearly did
not do that.
And so for Frankel.
That was basically.
That was basically his observations of
what happened in Nazi Germany and for
soldier an incident.
It was his observations of what happened
in this.
In establishing the Soviet Union and in
other places that were directly
committed to a comprehensive
totalitarian view of reality and their
observations were that as soon as that
totalitarian viewpoint was imposed and
everyone acted as if every problem had
been finally solved,
the immediate consequence of that was
that everyone had to lie about
everything they did in order to support
the system.
And the next consequence of that was the
system became radically genocidal and
murderous and so for Franklin soldier
Nitsa and their,
their.
Their diagnosis of that was that it was
necessary for individual people to adopt
a truthful relationship with being.
Because the consequence of not doing
that was the degeneration of everything
into something that basically resembled
hell.
And so you can align that idea with the
Piagetian idea of the game like
hierarchy and you can say something
like,
and this is also drawing on the idea,
say of Rogers and the ideas of,
of he described it as authentic being is
that the pathway to the appropriate
hierarchical organization of the
personality from the microcosm up to the
macrocosm is actually
fostered by your relationship with
truth.
You know,
and for for Rogers,
he talked about the physiological
psychophysiological manifestations of
that for rogers,
that was partly the willingness to
enter into a dialogue with your physical
being which which is also a notion that
the psychoanalysts push in a slightly
different direction because people like
Freud,
regardless of the fact that his notion
of what constitutes socialization was
to,
was to predicated on conflict.
One of the things that fried certainly
continually pointed out was that it was
necessary for you to bring all of the
diverse elements of your personality
into into the game,
right?
Do you work to repress things?
You weren't to forget things.
You weren't supposed to leave.
Elements of your being that were that
were troublesome and difficult to
integrate.
You weren't supposed to leave those
lying out where nothing could be done
with them and because the consequence of
that would be that those
dissociated parts of you would become
would become pathological and dangerous
and so they would pose a threat to you,
but also because if you didn't
incorporate
those cast off elements of being,
then your personality would be too weak
to prevail.
For Freud,
of course,
those that the probability was very high
that the cast off elements of being
would be those that were associated
fundamentally with aggression and with
sexuality because you might think that
those are the two most dangerous
motivational forces that people have at
hand,
but you know you're a pretty hollow in
thin person if you're not capable of
aggression,
and if your sexual morality is
continually as as only predicated on,
well your inability to engage in sexual
activity because no one wants you or
because you're repressing it and very
awkward and unskilled out.
It's in so that the question never even
arises.
You know that's.
That's the.
That's the approach people take when
they try to make their children's so
naive about sexuality and so protected
that they're terrified to have anything
to do with it whatsoever and that might
work very well.
As long as they're in a situation where
there are so
underdeveloped and repressed that no one
has wants to have anything to do with
them.
But as soon as they get out into the
world where sexual behavior,
for example,
starts to become a possibility.
All that does is leave them completely
open to their own pathologies,
into the predatory behavior of other
people.
It's not much of a solution.
Now,
the,
the existentialist idea and that's the
idea of authentic being is that the most
appropriate way to interact with being
as an emergency is is by maintaining
some relationship with truth.
Now it's a very difficult concept to to
really come to grips with because it's
of course,
as as is famously known.
It's not that easy to identify exactly
what constitutes truth.
I think that's part of the reason why
Franklin Solzhenitsyn,
when they were talking about the
existential approach to being.
We're more likely to concentrate on
false hood rather than on truth per se
because I think it's easier.
You can think about this yourself,
but I think it's easier for each of us
to identify when we're doing something
wrong than it is for us to determine
whether or not we happen to be on the
right path because the the issue of
whether right now you're doing something
wrong is simpler in some sense.
Then the question then,
then trying to understand whether the
sum total of all your actions right now
are those that will put you into the
appropriate place into the future.
So I think that as you establish a
relationship with truth,
the first thing that you try to do is to
start lying and that's not exactly the
same thing as telling the truth because
I would say you can't actually tell the
truth because you don't know what it is,
but you can certainly strive not to
talk,
not to speak or act in ways that you
know to be false.
And I think that by doing that,
that's part of how you,
you,
you integrate your personality and you
strengthen your personality across time
and also how you learn to understand
larger and larger sections of what might
actually be true rather than what
that
instead of only being able to identify
from moment to moment what's false.
No one character guard would say,
well,
there's.
There's an element of faith in a
decision like that.
And I can tell you a little bit about
what he meant.
So we know when we were talking about
Carl Rogers,
we talked about instrumental use of
language,
right?
So the idea there would be that I'm
using language constantly to get what I
want from the world in any given
situation.
The,
that instrumental use is predicated on
the idea that I know what I want and
that I know what's good for me.
And the problem is,
is that's a very,
um,
it's very unlikely that that's true
because you don't know what's good for
you in the final analysis because you're
too ignorant to know.
And so if you're using language to
manipulate the world to ensure that
things turn out the way you want them to
right now,
then you're acting as if your knowledge
about what constitutes the good is
sufficiently well developed and final so
that you can rely on it as a guide to
what you're going to say and do.
Now,
the alternative to that is something.
There is an alternative to that,
but it's a very complicated alternative.
And the alternative to that is something
more like,
it has more to do with reliance on your
capacity to transform.
Because here's an alternative to that
kind of rigid and manipulative approach
to life,
and the alternative is to try to act out
what you think is appropriate and to
save what you think is true as carefully
as you possibly can,
and then to see what happens
and that's a completely different way of
approaching the situation and it's a lot
more interesting.
No,
I mean,
one of the things I've been thinking
about is I truly believe that the idea
that that people speak potential into
being is accurate.
I think that what we face as we move
through life is a realm of potential
that's in front of us that we can
continually interact with and I think
that that's actually helped people think
about the world when they think about
it,
because we think of the future as a
place of diverse possibilities and we
think of the future as something we can
maneuver through and turning into
actuality.
Now.
That's what we think about when we,
when we think about potential and and
about realizing the potential in things
and the potential in ourselves and the
potential in other people.
Well then you ask yourself,
well,
what do you think?
What's the best technology that you have
at your disposal for transforming
potential into the kind of actuality
that you would actually want to see
around you?
And then you might ask yourself,
well,
is it more likely that you're going to
get the actuality that you want by
trying to trying to grapple with
potential in a truthful manner?
Or is it more likely that you're going
to get the kind of actuality that you
want?
You grappled with reality in a manner
that's rife with falsehood and I would
say,
well if,
if framing potential into actuality is
like building a house,
then I would say if you build a house
out of the proper materials,
then it might stand.
But if you build a house out of cap rate
materials and you,
you take shortcuts wherever you can and
you pretend things are other than what
they are.
Then as soon as the ground shakes,
your house is going to fall.
And that seems to me to be something
that's fundamentally undeniable.
You know,
if you mix too much sand in your
Samantha and your foundation is going to
be weak and you can do that merely by
ignoring what you know,
and so I think that the root out of
inauthentic being in the root out of our
proclivity to identify with,
with ultimately genocidal ideologies is
to attempt to establish a relationship
with being that's predicated on at least
not on falsehood,
at least that you know in.
One of the things Rogers would say,
and I think he's right about this,
is that if you consult the totality of
your being,
when you're acting and you're speaking,
you can tell by paying attention to the
way that you're responding to your
actions.
Enter your.
Enter your words whether or not what
you're doing and saying is pulling you
together and making you integrate it and
making you strong or whether it's
pulling you apart and disintegrate you
and making you weak and roll.
One of Roger's claims was that that's
actually a psychophysiological
sensations.
He called that.
You know,
he described that in association with
the wisdom of the body and are you
really believe that to be true?
I mean,
I can see this when I'm talking to
people when I'm talking to my clients or
when I'm talking to other people,
I can see as soon as they start to
misuse their words are start to use them
in an instrumental manner.
Like the strength goes out of them
completely and you can detect that
there's something shallow and false
going on and you know,
if you call people's attention to that
fact when it's happening,
they're often rather resistant to
noticing it.
But if they do open their eyes and pay
attention to it,
they can see right away that that's
what's occurring
now.
When we moved into it,
when we move towards Freud in Yom.
Well,
I mean I was extremely interested in
young and I have been extremely
interested in young because he's one of
the few things that I've ever
encountered who takes culture seriously
and he believes that it's necessary
because we're historical creatures and
we're.
We're shaped by historical facts that
it's necessary for us to understand our
culture and our past because we're
embodying it because we're historically
constructed creatures and so the reason
to study history is because history is
you and if you don't understand history
than history is gonna have it's gonna
have you in its clutches and it's going
to be moving you from place to place
because it was young who formulated the
idea,
for example,
that people don't have ideas.
That ideas have people and I think that
if you take that notion seriously,
it's one of the most frightening things
you can ever realized.
Because of course everyone thinks that
they have ideas.
But if you look at people,
for example,
who are possessed by an ideology,
obviously the idea has them because you
can predict exactly what they're going
to say and do.
In every situation.
You can predict exactly what solution
they're going to bring to the table.
Whenever you discuss any problem and if
you come up with an idea about a problem
and you come up with an idea about the
problem and it's the same idea,
the probability that it's you coming up
with it,
are you coming up with it is zero.
It's whatever it is that's coming up
with the same idea is the thing that's
got control.
You know when you see this with people
all the time,
when they arbitrarily divide the world,
for example,
up into those things that are good and
acceptable in those things that aren't.
You see this with right wingers and use
it with left-wingers because the right
wingers make the claim that government
is evil and the left wing makes the
claim that corporations are evil and if
you take five left wingers,
you can tell exactly what they're going
to say about any given problem.
And if you take five right wingers,
it's exactly the same thing.
So then that brings up the question,
who exactly is doing the talking and the
thinking?
Of course,
the people who are spouting those ideas,
things that they're doing the thinking,
but there's no reason to assume that
that's the case at all and I can tell
you something else that you can
determine right away.
People are dead boring when they're
spouting etiological clap trap.
You could hardly even listened to them,
but you can take virtually anyone
educated or uneducated,
and if they start to tell you the truth
about their own experience,
even if they do that in a stumbling way,
in a halting way,
they become fascinating instantly
because they're the only people who have
access to that information and it's rich
and deep information and you know that
it's personal.
It's,
it's,
it's material that they have a right to,
you know,
and they can intermingle that with ideas
that the culture has produced even in
theological ideas and come up with
something that's richer and more
brilliant as a consequence of that.
But if they're not speaking their own
words,
well,
first of all,
there's something else that's speaking
through them.
And second,
there's something about it.
It's dead.
So I don't remember if I told you the,
the origin of the word slogan,
so slogan comes from to Welsh words and
one is slew egg,
which is Slu a,
g,
H,
and the other is Gary,
g,
h a I r m.
So it's slew a Garren.
Garren means gerome means the battle cry
of the data and that to me is a perfect
example.
Often it's a perfectly example of how
fascinating the process by which he
words emerge actually is,
but it's also a dead accurate
description of what's speaking through a
person when their languages being
reduced to slogan and they're not paying
any attention to their own
individualized being.
And what it is is that it's the army of
the dead in some sense speaking through
them.
There's no spirit there.
There's nothing that's alive.
And I don't think that being possessed
by the army of the dead is a very good
idea.
I mean it's,
that's all wisdom that was useful for
the past and that's lost its ability to
be applicable to the president.
One of the other things that seems to me
that happen to people in university is
they don't really get educated about how
important what they do actually is,
you know,
and I think that goes along with the
nihilistic cast of modern,
of modern people.
You know,
it's easy to view yourself as one little
dust mote floating around in a,
uh,
you know,
in a stadium full of dust motes and air.
So you're all disconnected with each
other and none of you have any causal
impact on anyone else around the hole.
But I don't think there's any reason to
conceptualize yourself using that model
at all.
Because the first thing that is very
easy to notice is that you're very much
networked.
You know.
And so over the course of your life,
you're going to have direct and
relatively profound influence on several
thousand people.
And some of you may be more and some of
you less,
but we could certainly say a thousand
people,
you know,
in each of those thousand people will
know a thousand people.
And that's a million.
And one step past that is a billion.
And so you basically sit in the center
of a network that with very limited
extension covers virtually everyone on
the planet,
and that's becoming more and more true
rather than less and less true as
everyone becomes increasingly networked
and connected.
And so what that implies is that the
things that you do that you choose to
do,
or the things that you choose not to do,
are going to have effects that ripple
far beyond your particular individual
existence.
And so part of what that means is that
all of the choices that you make as
you're confronting that unstructured
future as you move through your life are
going to alter the structure of being
itself.
You know,
and one of the things that
I've showed you guys repeatedly,
that hierarchy of action right there
with a highest resolution level being
the things that you actually do with
your body,
the muscle movements that you manifest
in the world and,
and showed you how those are
hierarchically organized into higher and
higher systems of value.
You know?
And when I showed you that hierarchy,
the thing I put at the top was be a good
person.
Well,
I think that that can be elaborated out
in a reasonable manner so that it's
possible to understand more and more
being a good person is about.
Part of it is that you have to have
organized yourself into something that's
well structured and useful and I think
you do that by disciplining yourself and
by adopting some role in the world
that's that's meaningful and profound so
that you have to so that the so that the
stress and demands of of that organized
you into something that's that's strong
and flexible and productive and so
that's one element of it.
I think of that as a kind of
apprenticeship element and I think I
learned that mostly from nature because
one of nature's claims was that in order
to become properly developed as a human
being,
you had to undergo a position.
A.
You had to undergo a process of
voluntary slavery.
In some sense.
You had to.
You had to give yourself over to some
sort of role.
Perhaps it doesn't even matter what role
so that you became an expert at that and
that was going to cost you in that
you're going to be bent and twisted into
that role,
but it's also going to discipline and
organize you and the alternative is to
become nothing you know and that's not a
useful alternative.
So you want to become something and then
once you become something,
well then you want to be able to
transform that something into,
into whatever is necessary at that
particular point.
And I think that that's where the ideas
that are associated with heroin
mythology start to become particularly
relevant to considerations of higher
order ethics.
Because the hero,
the hero in mythology is the hero in
mythology,
is the representation of the human being
in so far as mankind understands what it
is to be human and what the hero does is
confront the things that he or she does
not understand and take what's valuable
from that confrontation and then
reintegrated into the personality and
the society.
That's why the hero goes out to where
the dragon is and takes the gold and
then brings the gold back to the
community and distributes it,
and so I would say,
well,
part of being a good person is being
good for something and then another part
of being a good person is being better
than being good for something because
you want to be not only good for
something,
but you want to be able to be good for
something in a way that keeps making you
better and better at being good for
something.
And that means you can't just be
It means that you have to become
something constantly.
And I,
and I think that the tremendous amount
of what constitutes the intrinsic
meaning of life can be found in that
attempt to continually expand and
reorganize as you're expanding.
Because this is a union idea.
I mean human beings are cognitively
dynamic creatures and we find intrinsic
worth in participating in that
cognitively dynamic process.
So.
And then I think outside of that,
there's another question which is,
well,
what it is,
what is it exactly you're aiming at?
And My,
my experience has taught me,
and this is partly a consequence of
studying archetypes for a very long
period of time,
I think the fundamental question that's
on the very outer reaches of the
hierarchy that's associated with ethics
and morality is,
are you trying to make the world a
better place or a worse place?
And I believe that every time you make a
decision when you could go one way or
you could go another,
that in some sense you're acting out
your conviction in relationship to that
highest order question.
No one you say,
well,
would people really work to make the
world a worse place?
And the answer to that is,
well,
if you have to ask that question,
then you should open your eyes because
we know the answer to that.
The old 20th century was full of have
decades and decades.
In fact,
the primary,
I think the primary,
the most important information that you
can derive from an analysis of the 20th
centuries that is pretty damn certain
that people are willing to work to make
everything as terrible as they possibly
can.
And that's definitely worth considering
because if people are willing to do that
and motivated to do that,
that probably means that you're willing
to do that motivated to do it too,
and I think it's fairly easy to
understand why.
I think the reason that people are
motivated to do that sort of thing is to
do terrible things is because they're
angry at the conditions of their life.
They're angry at the conditions of being
because being is is composed of
suffering and vulnerability and people.
People lose and they suffer and they get
resentful and angry about that and they
feel hard done by and that the entire
structure of the world is aimed against
them in some unfair manner and then they
get resentful and corrupt and feel that
everything that they do is justifiable.
Given how much torment and suffering
they've been living through and from.
Once you make the.
Once you move into that particular realm
of thinking,
your ability to start to make things
worse starts to accelerate
exponentially.
And I don't believe there's a single
person on the planet who hasn't been in
a situation where something has happened
to them that sufficiently disappointing
and tragic so that their thoughts turned
to revenge and destruction.
Think that harms to people all the time
and it's understandable,
but the problem is it seems to be
extraordinarily counterproductive and
all it does is make the situation that
everybody's complaining about worse
instead of better.
And so what seems to be the cases that
you have to bear the fact that you're
incomplete and,
and I'm vulnerable and underdeveloped in
and weak in many ways without becoming
vengeful and corrupted by your knowledge
of that and,
and well still trying to do everything
you can to make the,
to make being better rather than worse.
And
I think the upside of that mode of
thinking is I don't believe that there's
anything more engaging and interesting
then continued attempts to make things
better.
A problem is it requires the adoption of
a tremendous amount of responsibility.
Right?
And I think that it's the unwillingness
to accept responsibility that stops
people from waking up and becoming
enlightened.
No,
if if you want to make the world a
better place,
then you have to take responsibility for
all of the.
All of the ways that you look at the
world and everything that you act out
and all the things that you say and it
means you have to pay a tremendous
amount of attention to what you're doing
as a consequence.
And that's,
that's very difficult and it's also
frightening because it means that you
have to entertain the hypothesis that
the things that you're doing are
important.
Am I think part of the reason why?
Why our culture has taken such a
nihilistic Bantus because people have
actually decided that life would be a
lot easier if it didn't have any
meaning.
People run around and complain about the
fact that life is meaninglessness or
that life is meaningless and we've,
you know,
we've drawn that conclusion from both a
rational and empirical perspective and
people will tell you that they came to
that conclusion purely logically and
scientifically.
But when I looked at that claim,
might think,
well,
maybe you want life to be beating list
because it lets you off the hook.
If everything you do hasn't gotten any
value,
then why do you have to pay any
attention to it?
You can do whatever you want and if it's
the opposite,
if everything you do has meaning and
it's important,
well then you better be awake because
what you do matters and then you get all
the meaning you want at the price you
have to pay for.
That is that you have to take
responsibility now and if you start to
seriously entertain the idea that with
every decision you take,
you're tilting the world either towards
heaven or towards hell.
Then that can instantly start making you
a lot more serious about what you choose
to do and not do.
And My.
My understanding of personality
development and personality development
in relationship to history is that that
is exactly what is the case.
When you're making decisions in your
life,
you face a a field of infinite potential
and you use your will for good or evil
in order to shape it into what it's
going to be.
And that's really what a human being is.
A human being is the sort of creature
that can do that.
And you know,
one of the things I've found,
it's extremely interesting is that there
is an idea at the very core of most
modern legal systems.
It's certainly the case for English
common law,
which I think is the most sophisticated
legal system that's ever been developed.
And it's predicated on an idea that
every single person has intrinsic worth,
you know,
that sort of the ground of the idea of
natural rights.
And so I spend a lot of time looking
into that idea is why is it that,
why is it that the idea that each person
has intrinsic worth ever developed,
especially when you look at the
situation and you see that,
well,
some people are clearly doing everything
they can to make the world as an
absolutely terrible place.
You know,
under English common law for example,
even if you're a serial killer and
everyone knows it,
you still have rights before the law.
And there's an idea there that no matter
how corrupt you've become,
there's still something that's
intrinsically valuable about you.
And you know,
people in the modern world claim that
they don't have any metaphysical
beliefs.
But in so far as you're an advocate of
the legal system that claims that people
have intrinsic worth,
then you're acting out the idea that
there's something of value about every
single person and then you might ask,
well,
what is it that might be a value of
every single person and if it's,
it might easily be that it's the faculty
that each person has to turn potential
into actuality.
And I would say that if you do an
analysis of the fundamental basis of
modern law then and you and you and you
go down into the understructure of the
ideas that gave rise to that entire body
of law.
What you find is that is the idea at the
bottom of it.
No,
what's the idea in some sense that
people are made in the image of God and
it's God who makes order out of chaos
and sometimes turns chaos into and
sometimes turns order into chaos when
that becomes necessary and people are
capable of doing that.
So I think that we're continually
involved in the cocreation of reality
and that we can choose what sort of
reality we want to bring into existence.
So when you can do that in a resentful
and murderous way and you have every
reason to do it,
but it seems to me to be the wrong
choice and you'll pay a big price for
doing that.
You pay a big price for doing that every
second of your life.
The things that I've been talking to you
about for the entire course,
you know,
there are things that I've tried to put
into practice in one way or another.
You know,
when I'm,
when I'm engaged in therapy with people,
what I'm really trying to do is to
listen to what they have to say.
No,
I don't.
I don't really want to give them advice
because the advice isn't that helpful.
But usually what we try to do is we've
tried to lay out what the problem is.
You know,
and that's a consequence of mutual
discussion because often people don't
really know why they're troubled.
You know,
they have some ideas about it and they
can talk about the situation in their
family and the fact that their
relationships aren't going well and so
forth,
but it's no easy matter to actually
specify the problem because if things
aren't going well for you,
it's not necessarily the case that you
know why you might know some of it.
You might even know that there's some
things that you're doing that you should
stop doing,
but you can't stop doing them.
So a lot of the initial discussion is
mirrored delineation of what the problem
constitutes and then the next part of
the discussion as well.
If that's the problem,
what would a solution look like?
Which be how could things be better than
they are now?
What would that,
what would that actually look like?
And then the next issue is,
well,
what steps could you put into place to
start moving towards that goal?
And that's all an exploratory process.
You know,
and I think it's a process that's
basically grounded in a search for the
truth.
And what I found in my psychotherapy
practice is that in so far as that's
happening during the discussions,
then the process itself is
extraordinarily gripping.
You know,
when you,
you,
I think you also experienced that
whenever you sit down with someone and
have a conversation that serious and
meaningful conversation like that grips
you.
And I think the reason for that is
because you are in the right place at
the right time,
so to speak.
And what you're doing is important and
meaningful.
It's difficult though because you have
to face up to what the problems actually
are and you have to pay careful
attention and you have to run through
all the options and you have to plan
strategically and you have to be careful
about what you said.
You can't get too self aggrandizing,
Redo,
egotistical and you can't offer simple
solutions.
But it's an incredibly engaging process.
You know,
it's,
it's like reading the highest quality
fiction in some sense.
And so a lot of conversations between
people can be like that.
If both people who are engaged in the
conversation and this is something
Rogers pointed out,
you know,
are willing to admit that there is in
fact the problem and then to do whatever
is necessary to lay out the structure of
that broad meant to solve it and that's,
that's admission of vulnerability too to
a large degree.
And it seems to me that that process
actually works,
you know,
it facilitates trust,
which is extraordinarily useful.
I mean,
with some of my clients,
it's taken me years before we can
actually have a genuine conversation
because they're so afraid of engaging in
a discussion that's actually real and
genuine and exposing their,
their actual problems that,
that,
you know,
they hide often behind the sorts of
things that you described as a persona.
You can't get to the real person because
there's so covered up by a shell that,
that you can't have a genuine
discussion.
And the reason that's the case is
because,
you know,
they've attempted to engage in genuine
interactions with people in the past and
they've been betrayed or hurt or
undermined in some way.
That's really profound.
And so they learned that that's very
dangerous to do that,
which is exactly true,
but it's a lot more dangerous not to do
it.
So
one of the things that I hope for when I
teach this class and the other classes
that I teach too,
is that people can come out of the
classes with a different
conceptualization of what they might
actually be like.
No.
And I really do believe that people are
remarkable creatures,
know the extent of our capacity by no
means known.
And there's so much about what we're
like that we don't understand.
We have no idea what it means that each
of us is a locus of consciousness.
You know,
and obviously,
you know,
I don't know if you know this,
but the word genie is the root word of
genius.
And the idea of the GE is a very
interesting idea,
right?
Because with a genie you have this
incredible capacity for magical power in
some sense,
all collapsed into this incredibly tiny
container.
And so there's this weird constraint
between the divine possibility of the
genie and the fact that it's
encapsulated into this unbearably tiny
space.
And in some senses trapped inside that,
but the reason that genie is the root
word of genius is because that's exactly
what people are like,
that we have this incredible capacity
for imagination and for speaking things
into being and for acting things into
being.
But at the same time,
we're limited by our frame in time and
space.
It limits us,
but it also allows us potential.
It's a very strange set of limitations.
One of the things I've wondered very
deeply over the last 20 years is,
you know,
that people are often upset about the
structure of being.
There's a good argument in the brothers
Karamazov,
um,
they,
the brothers Karamazov features a very,
a very large number of characters that
has a very Friday and eat a whole
subplot.
But one of the,
one of the continual battles between
characters in the brothers Karamazov is
a battle between a young man named
Elisha who is going to be a monk in a
monastery and he's trying to live a
classically good life.
You know,
uh,
traditionally good life as it might've
been conceived of in 18,
18 and 18 seventies.
And his brother Ivan,
who is an older brother who's extremely
intelligent,
charismatic,
and very rationalistic and arrogant and
and creative and intelligent.
And he likes nothing better than to go
after her lowest share with all the
stories about the horrors of the world
to try to undermine his faith in the
divinity that he's attempting to
establish a relationship with them.
So we tell stories like this is a story
that does DSD took out of the newspaper
in approximately the time when he was
reading the brothers Karamazov.
And it's a story about this.
This family,
this father and mother locked there are
three or four year old daughter and a
freezing out house overnight.
And she was screaming the entire time to
have someone let her out and they let
her freeze to death and the outhouse.
And of course that produced a big
scandal.
And one of the things that Ivan Ivan
uses,
that story or Dostoevsky uses that story
in the brothers Karamazov so that Ivan
can torture Lee Osha about the fact that
you know there's no way that you could
possibly envision that being itself
could be good or that God could be good
if you want to put it a different way
when that sort of thing can happen in
the world and that it happens over and
over and over all the time,
everywhere you know,
and and Dostoevsky because he's no
piker.
When he sets up an argument between two
positions,
he sets up the argument as powerfully as
he possibly can.
And so he has already been tell Osha
endless stories like that and make the
claim that as far as revenue is
concerned,
that the mere fact that any of those
things could have ever happened.
Even once.
A sufficient reason to never,
never allow yourself to conceptualize
the idea.
That being itself might be good fact.
Ivan's presupposition is that it's evil
enough so that it should be eradicated
in one.
Any
any game that has that element of play
and it is a game that should never be
played.
That's basically Ivan stance and that's
a very.
That's a very archetipal stance by the
way.
It's the same stance that Mephistopheles
adoption group,
this faust,
and it's the same stance that Lucifer
adopts in paradise lost.
It's the rational opposition to be a and
and it's a very powerful idea,
but there's something wrong about it
because if you pursue that and you act
it out rigorously and consistently,
then all that happens is you turn into
someone who adds to the misery rather
than putting an end to it and one of the
things I've wondered is,
and this is something that's worth
thinking about.
If everybody abandoned their
pathological nihilism and despair and
did what they could to make things
better,
wherever they could,
then maybe we could turn the world into
a place where that sort of thing didn't
happen and then what?
Then what would that be like?
No,
because you ask yourself why have you
done everything you possibly can to put
your life in order?
And if the answer to that is no,
then what makes you think you have any
right to complain about the conditions
of your existence?
There's a story in Tsl.
Iots play the cocktail hour and the
story involves a woman who's thinking
about seeking psychiatric treatment and
she approaches a psychiatrist and she
basically says,
I really hope there's something wrong
with me.
And the psychiatrist says,
well,
why do you hope that there's something
wrong with you?
And she says,
well,
I'm having a really miserable time of
it.
And as far as I can tell,
that means that there's only two
options.
Either I'm doing something wrong and
there's something wrong with me and
that's the reason that all this
pointless suffering seems to be
occurring.
Or there's something wrong with the
structure of being per se that makes all
of this inevitable,
you know?
And that's a perfectly reasonable laying
out of two options.
And so she says,
well,
I hope that we can start to discover
what it is that I'm doing wrong because
it would be a lot better if the reason
things weren't so good was because I was
doing something wrong.
Then it would be if the reason that
things are wrong is because they're just
wrong and there's nothing you can do
about it.
Well,
it's an easy question to answer because
that's an existential question.
You know,
what's the sort of thing that you can
only answer over the course of your
entire life and it's the sort of
question that no one else can answer for
you,
but one thing you can find out is just
what your life would be like if you
stopped making it unnecessarily
miserable.
You know when to do that.
You have to abandon your
dissatisfaction,
your vengefulness and your resentment
and your arrogance and your willful
blindness and all those things that stop
you from seeing what's right in front of
your face and try to make things as
straight as you possibly can in those
places that you can make them.
And as far as I can tell if you do that,
I think it's what I teach my clients to
do in psychotherapy.
If they do that,
their lives get a lot better and I don't
know exactly how good your life could
get,
but I don't think that there's any
necessary upper limit so people can
figure out how to set things right.
And the,
you know,
the more you practice that in the places
you can actually practice it,
the better and better you get at that in
the more things that you can set.
Right.
You know,
and then you're also not setting other
people.
Right.
Which I also think there's something
extremely useful because my suspicions
are that you have enough to do just
setting yourself right without having to
worry about all the other people that
are running around mocking up the
planet,
which,
and you don't know what to do with them
many ways or what they should be doing.
So it's just as well to start with
yourself.
It's an extremely useful adventure and
it's something that will never allow you
to become board even for a moment.
And that's worth something to,
you know,
because even if life is fundamentally
suffering and there's nothing that can
be done about that,
which is a possibility,
there's always the possibility that you
could learn to live in a manner so that
that suffering was actually justifiable
even to you because you might say,
well,
what I'm doing is so much worthwhile
that even if I have to suffer to do it,
it's worth it and I would say that's
actually the ethical imperative for your
life is that you're obliged to find
something to do and some way of doing it
that's so deeply meaningful,
but the fact that you have to carry
around your mortal vulnerability is
something that you can accept and even
be happy about.
Because the alternative is gloomy and DM
and it's worse than that.
It's not just gloomy and DMD.
It's gloomy and dam and then it's
beneficial and then it's murderous.
And Ben,
it's genocidal and that seems to be
something that we could really do
without.
So I'm hoping that as a consequence of
having taken this course,
that you have some expanded idea of what
it might mean to be a human being and
that you can carry that with you as you
move forward in your life and find out
what you really liked and find out what
you could do if you put your mind to it
because God only knows what you could do
if you put your mind to it,
you know,
and the more people who are doing that,
the better things are going to get.
And that would be a good thing because
things aren't so bad,
but they could be a lot better.
And it's hard to say just exactly how
much you could contribute to that.
If you decided that that's what it was
that you could do,
and I do believe that is what you can
do.
I also believe that you are doing that.
You're shaping the world for better or
for worse,
regardless of whether or not you decide
to do it and take on the responsibility.
You're basically destined to do that.
So it seems to me that you should make
that conscious and decide if you're
going to do it properly or if you're
going to make things worse.
So.
Well,
I guess the other thing I have to say is
that I wish you luck as you proceed
through your university career.
I mean this is an awkward institution in
many ways and your,
your faceless and numbered while you're
here,
but it's also a place where it's the
fact that you're engaged in this
university means that the social
community has given you an identity
that's acceptable.
You're a student and that's an honorable
thing to be.
And that means that you can spend a few
years trying to learn the most important
things that you have to learn and that
you're,
you're granted a role that makes that
acceptable.
Unjustifiable and I would say,
well,
you've got a couple of years here,
you know,
and the wisdom of the world is collected
at the University of Toronto and it's
going to be discussed and displayed
awkwardly by your professors because
they're incomplete incarnations of
historical wisdom.
But you should forgive them for that and
try to do everything you possibly can to
extract everything you possibly can out
of this place while you're here.
Because if you do it properly,
then it's going to make your life a lot
richer and more productive than it could
otherwise be.
And you might say,
well,
what about getting a job?
And I would say,
well,
if you learn to think and you learn to
speak and you learn to act properly and
you learn how to be articulate and you
conduct yourself with a certain amount
of wisdom and grace,
you'll never have to worry for one
minute in your life about what you're
going to do that will sustain you and be
productive.
Because people like that are an
unbelievably short supply and all the
people out there in the world who have
some sense and there's quite a few
people like that are desperately looking
for people like that.
And if you happen to be one of them,
you will have more opportunities in your
life than you possibly know what to do
with.
So I don't think you have to worry too
much about exactly what you're going to
be or what role you're going to play
when you come out.
If you prepare yourself and you turn
yourself into an articulate and honest
and educated person.
People like that are incredibly
valuable.
And as I said already,
if you transform yourself into someone
who's like that,
the world will open doors for you in
ways you can't possibly imagine.
It will happen in ways you don't even
understand.
I mean,
I see this with students who do the
opposite,
you know,
so with my graduate students and
sometimes with undergraduates as well,
I'll give one of them a job to do,
you know,
and they'll either do it and do it well,
are there come back and tell me why it
was impossible for,
for them to do it and how many things
got in the way.
And the consequences of that is that for
the person who comes and tells me that
they don't get another opportunity and
for the person who comes and does and
has done what I asked them to do,
or maybe going over and above the,
you know,
the call of duty,
then I have six more opportunities for
them or maybe 20 more opportunities for
them or maybe 50 more opportunities for
them because I have more opportunities
that I know what to do with.
And so it turns out that if you're the
sort of person who is useful and direct
and honest,
then invisible doors will open for you
everywhere.
And if you're not,
then invisible doors will shut until no
doors are open and you'll think you'll
curse fate for that and complaint about
the structure of being.
But the reason it's like that is because
you didn't take the opportunities when
they were offered to you and you didn't
do things properly.
So you can learn how to do things
properly at university and you can turn
yourself into someone who's a lot wiser
than you were when you first came here.
And there isn't anything that's more
valuable than wisdom and truth,
and so I would say you take the next
couple of years while you're here.
See if you can turn yourself into
something that's useful and honest and
you'll be so prepared for life,
you won't be able to believe it,
and there's absolutely no reason to be
cynical about that because I seen how
the world works and that is how it
works.
So.
So I wish you well while you attempt to
do that.
And I hope that you've learned something
in this course that enables you to do
that in a manner that's more powerful
than richer and more worthwhile and less
nihilistic and less cynical and more
meaningful because that would be a good
thing if it happened.
And so it was a pleasure to teach you
this year and I wish you the best of
luck as you proceed through your
education.
Thank you.